The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome to 6.172,
Performance Engineering of
Software Systems.
This is a fun class.
It's all about going fast.
We all like to go fast--
well, not all of us.
But everybody in this class
likes to go fast.
Otherwise you won't like
the class very much.
It's all about making
stuff go fast.
So a couple of brief
announcements.
We're going to be videotaping
for OpenCourseWare.
So if you don't want to be
videotaped, you should sit it
in a place where the camera
won't catch you.
Because we're in such a large
classroom, I'd like everybody
to sort of every day, without
me having to draw--
I'm not really an artist.
My sister's an artist,
actually.
She's a painter.
But maybe that gene
escaped me.
It went that way and
not this way.
So I don't want to have
to draw it up again.
So everybody, try to confine
yourself to this sort of
quarter of the classroom.
And that way, it'll feel more
like a size room that
we ought to be in.
Let me go to our course
information sheet.
Did everybody get a copy of the
course information handout?
So we're going to the class--
we're going to start at the
beginning with the Administrivia
stuff, try to
run through that as
quickly as we can.
And then my co-lecturer,
professor Saman Amarasinghe--
if you can't pronounce or spell
his last name, you can
just say "Saman"--
will give today's lecture.
And we have four teaching
assistants.
So teaching assistants,
please stand up.
They are Josh, John,
Reed, and Eric.
And let me tell you, what they
have done in the last few days
to get us ready for this course
is nothing short of
superhuman.
So you really need to accord
them your respect, and they're
going to really work hard
to help you folks do
well in this class.
We have, I think, a pretty
decent ratio.
I think even with concerns about
cutbacks, et cetera, to
have four TAs for this
is really good.
And we need it, because
it's a software class.
And software is, as you know,
bugs can take an arbitrarily
long time to find.
You guys can sit.
Besides our teaching assistants,
we have two
support staff people helping us,
Mary McDavitt, who works
for Saman, and Marcia Davidson,
who works for me.
And they're generally pretty
good about being able to track
us down if we're in
some far corner of
the world or something.
Our lectures are going to be
held on Tuesdays and Thursdays
in this room, 2:30 to 4:00 PM.
You should plan to
attend regularly.
We dispense all kinds of
wonderful gems that you will
miss if you think you're going
to get it just from reading
and even looking at videotapes
or whatever.
I'm not sure what our
arrangement is going to be
about having videos available.
OK, they're not going to be
available, except unless
there's something really
extenuating circumstance.
You have to go into a hospital
to have your forebrain removed
or something--
something serious, OK?
All material in the lecture,
even if it's delivered oral,
is fair game for projects
and quizzes.
We will post the lecture
slides, but they don't
generally convey all
of the information.
And we're going to be
video-recorded, as I mentioned.
If you don't want to appear, sit
behind the camera, and you
won't appear.
We have no recitations
in this class.
However, the teaching assistants
will periodically
hold primers where we will
bring you up to speed on
various technologies that you
may not be up to speed in,
such as C. How many people have
programmed in C before?
And how many have not programmed
in C before?
A few.
OK.
Tools such as VTune.
Who's used VTune before?
Who has not used VTune?
Good.
Pin-- who's used Pin?
OK.
Who has used Cilk++?
OK, a couple people.
So you see, we're going to have
some primers to bring you
up to speed in those
kinds of things.
We don't expect that you came
in knowing any of those
things, particularly.
We're going to be using
Stellar for our course
management.
And here's the URL.
And you should make sure that
you're registered as a member
of 6.172, because otherwise,
you're not going to get any
announcements.
We're going to do all of our
administration through Stellar.
So make sure that you're
registered there.
At the end of today, I think
it is, we'll send out an
announcement to the student
mailing list.
If you don't get something
by the end today--
so you wake up tomorrow morning,
you have no email
from the course staff.
What that means is you
should email us.
AUDIENCE: Well, that mailing
list would be the
preregistered ones.
PROFESSOR: That'd be the
And then that way, we'll
get all the people.
So if you know you're not
preregistered, you can send us
email before then.
There are two one-hour quizzes
given during class time.
AUDIENCE: One and a half.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: One and a half hour.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're right.
It's one and a half
hour quizzes.
Yes, two one and a half
We'll correct that in
the online version.
Given during class time.
Can somebody, by the way,
correct this as we go along?
Great.
The dates are on the course
calendar, which is available
on Stellar.
We've had mixed results with the
ICS feed from Stellar, but
you're supposed to be able to
download the calendar to your
iPhone or other ICS-capable
devices.
But we were successful in
downloading, but all the times
were screwed up.
But anyway, hopefully, maybe
they'll allow that.
But anyway, the calendar
is there.
The quizzes will generally be
closed book and closed notes,
but you will be permitted crib
sheets, one sheet that you
summarize anything that you feel
that you need to know.
Generally, everything that we
cover in here is fair game for
the quizzes, including
things that are in
prerequisite courses.
There is no final exam because
we have a final project.
This is a fast-moving class, so
if you get caught behind,
it's not a good sign, because
it's really hard to work
double-hard to keep
up in this class.
You really have to keep
on top of things.
And so for that reason
and others--
because it's really
difficult for us--
it's fast moving for
us as well--
we generally cannot accept
late projects.
If you haven't been able to
complete a project, you should
just package up your partial
solution and hand that in, and
you'll get partial
credit on it.
Do not just say, oh, I'm not
going to hand something in,
and expect it to get
it done later.
If you do find yourself in an
unusual situation which you
think there are some extenuating
circumstances,
like the aforementioned brain
surgery or something, let us
know in advance.
So if you're going to get in
a car accident, it's really
helpful if you tell us the day
before so that we can plan.
Obviously can't always do that,
but if it is something
for which there is any
reasonable expectation it
should be done beforehand,
you should let us know.
And we may require, for those
kinds of exceptions, some kind
of confirmation from a dean
or medical professional.
So if that's the route that
you're in, you can plan a
little bit and make sure that
those confirmations
are on their way.
The grading, this is essentially
approximately how
we're going to grade.
As you can see, there's a
bunch of content in the
projects and a bunch
in the quizzes.
And then there's also
participation grade.
And the participation
is both in--
we will have design reviews and
such, so that's part of
the participation,
as well as asking
questions and such in class.
And because we're
video-recording everything, we
know exactly who's asking
questions, unless you choose
to sit outside the video zone.
In addition, if there is a
significant missing element to
your work, it doesn't matter how
well you did on the other
things, you will receive
a failing grade.
You must, essentially,
do all the work.
So if you do not get substantial
credit on the
final project or any other two
assignments, for example, you
can expect to receive
a failing grade.
It goes downhill very quickly.
If you're missing one
assignment, generally don't
expect to get higher than
a C, for example.
It goes downhill very, very
quickly, because that's what
this is all about is hands on.
What's permissible
in this class?
So it's your responsibility to
satisfy both the letter and
spirit of the rules.
So if you have any questions,
let us know.
Here's what the rules are.
Also, let me just say how
Saman and I treat this.
We have been involved in
cheating incidents off and on
over the years.
I've been at MIT almost
30 years.
Saman, you've been here--
PROFESSOR: 13.
PROFESSOR: 13 years.
So we've been here long time,
longer than you folks.
We've been through this
a bunch of times.
It's really a pain when
somebody cheats.
It robs me of a huge amount of
my time that I could otherwise
be spending on teaching and
students and my own
professional development.
However, we both take cheating
incidents extremely seriously.
So we have this thing that is
sometimes really inconvenient
called integrity.
And I'd rather, if I find
somebody's cheating, just give
you an F and not deal with it.
Drat.
Instead, when somebody's
cheating, I tend to want to
take it to the Committee on
Discipline, where you face
things like expulsion,
et cetera.
So I don't like to do that.
It's very time consuming
for me.
But I find it hard to just look
the other way, because I
view the issue of integrity as
protecting the vast majority
of students who are
obeying the rules.
So when a cheating incident
occurs, I sort of feel honor
bound to push it to its
proper conclusion.
So please don't cheat.
We will use a variety of means
at our disposal, including
technological ones, to
detect cheating.
Also, if you think that sharing
your results with
somebody else means
that they're
cheating and you're not--
in some cultures that's
the way it's treated--
no.
In this culture, in particular
the culture in this classroom,
they're both equally guilty of
academic dishonesty, whether
you are the giver
or the taker.
Equally, we treat that
as equal offense.
So here's the particular
things.
You may not share, generally,
your solutions with people who
are not in your group.
So we will have a bunch
of group projects,
generally in pairs.
And that includes both people
in the class and people
outside the class.
So generally, you keep
things to yourself.
When you're in a group, of
course, you can share ideas
within the group.
But we expect that everybody's
making a fair contribution.
So you should be concerned if
you are not holding up your
end of your group
participation.
And we're going to ask you to
describe the contributions of
the people in your group.
Generally, the group,
as I say, is two.
So it's basically saying,
what did you do?
How did you divide
up your project?
What did you do?
What did the other person do?
You generally can't share
it with anybody else.
You can't copy or transcribe
solutions from other places.
The work you submit
must be your own.
Pretty straightforward.
You may go out and use general
conceptual material, such that
you might get from a good
textbook or from Wikipedia or
someplace like that.
That's perfectly fine, resources
you would ordinarily
have available.
But if you do use any material
from an external source, you
should properly cite it in
normal academic that fashion.
Cite where it is so that
somebody else can go and find
and look to see what it
is that you're citing.
If you feel that you have
transgressed in
some way, let us know.
It always goes way easier.
I generally tend to be kind of a
nice guy when somebody comes
to me saying, oops, verses I
hear from somewhere else or
one of our tools detects
something else.
Then I'm kind of cranky.
So I'd rather, if you come to
me, we could work something
out, generally.
Most of your out-of-class
time will spent
completing six projects.
And there's an outline of
what the projects are.
They're all fun projects.
You can ask the TAs.
The TAs will tell you how much
fun they are, because they've
generally helped to design
and built their own
solutions to them.
Some will be done in pairs,
some individually.
The final project can either be
done in pairs or in threes,
I think we said.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, we also have--
we didn't put that in here.
We also have a Project 0, which
will be available today
after class.
So you should go to Stellar
and get Project 0.
Project 0 is not to
be handed in.
It's getting warmed up with all
of the machines and tools
that we'll be using
in the class.
We have been very fortunate to
have very nice contributions
from Dell and Intel of a new
Cluster facility that has 16
12-core machines.
And they're Intel Core
i7 machines.
Each chip has six cores, and
there's two cores per machine,
each with 48 gigabytes
of memory.
So these are kind of honking
modern facility.
So as I say, it's fun.
It's fun when you do something
on your laptop, and then you
go and you do it on one
of these machines and
it goes like this.
It's really fun when these
things go fast.
So Project 0, you should
start on today.
And it's basically the handout
called Getting Started.
It will be available
on Stellar.
And it will take you through
getting access to these
machines and so forth.
In particular, in order to use
these machines, you must have
a CSAIL account.
Who does not have
a CSAIL account?
So that is going to be the first
thing you need to do,
because you've got
to get that.
So what you want to do is get
registered for a CSAIL account--
and we give instructions
in there.
It's basically going
to a web page--
pretty much as soon as you
get out of the classroom.
Because you won't be able to
start anything until you have
this CSAIL account.
And hopefully, we'll be able
to give you access within a
few hours after you register.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: What operating
systems are the tools--
PROFESSOR: Linux.
We'll be using Linux.
So there are a variety of ways
that we describe for how you
use these machines remotely.
We have the Andrew
File System--
AFS--
which you can use so that you
can edit things locally but
have an SSH terminal window on
the machine, which makes it
very convenient.
On the other hand, for some
people, often some dorm rooms
with poor connectivity, doing
things by AFS may be
too slow for you.
But there are a variety of other
ways that you can-- you
can actually edit right
on the machine.
And there are a variety of ways
of having a repository on
your machine, because we'll
be using Git as
our versioning mechanism.
So you'd be able to have it
there and be able to make
copies back on the
other machine.
So there are a variety
of ways to work.
And you're free to make the
software run on your own
laptops or workstations.
The one thing I'll say is we
will not support that.
We don't have the resources to
support beyond using the
machines that we actually
provide.
I think I've got to
go faster here.
So let's see.
So software engineering.
So research in programmer
productivity has demonstrated
that pair programming, where two
programmers sit together,
one at the keyboard and one
looking on, is actually faster
than two programmers
coding separately.
Why do you suppose that is?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You don't get stuck.
The other person can tell you--
it's like when you're
[INAUDIBLE] writing on the
blackboard, you get nervous.
You don't know what
you're doing.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you
could be stuck.
What else?
AUDIENCE: You don't
procrastinate.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you don't
That's a good one.
Don't procrastinate.
AUDIENCE: Finding bugs.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, finding bugs.
So the main one is finding bugs,
that the person who's
looking on finds bugs.
In fact, I was just pair
programming with Reed the
other day, and we were trying
to figure out, why is this
thing not working?
And I say, gee, it looks fine.
It says, next y equals x.
And he says, no, next y is
supposed to equal y.
And it's like, we had both read
over that code, but as
soon as I spelled it out,
I didn't even notice.
But of course, him in hearing it
says, oh, it's supposed to
be x and y and y, not x and y.
So anyway, that kind of thing,
you pick up very quickly.
It makes it very
easy to debug.
Likewise, regression testing
demonstrably promotes fast
co-development.
So this is where you build a
battery of tests that includes
tests for every mistake
that you've ever made.
And it can also be helpful to
write unit tests, where you
test individual ones.
And you should also use tools
like the assert package.
And some of these things will be
taken through in Project 0.
The MIT POSSE.
We have recruited senior
software engineers in the
region to share with you their
invaluable knowledge and
experience.
We call them Masters In The
Practice Of Software Systems
Engineering, which has the
great acronym MIT POSSE.
These are people who
are not being paid.
And they're senior.
They're doing this because
they're volunteering, because
they want to help.
You have a lot to learn from
these people, and we will have
code and design reviews with
these people with your
assigned master.
You want to treat them nicely.
They're not doing this so that
some snotty-nosed kid can say,
I don't care about you.
That's not what they're doing.
They're there to help you
get a good grade.
And these are some really
talented people, people who
are very famous in their
own areas of expertise.
So be gracious, is the main
thing I would say.
Be gracious.
Let's see.
The assignments.
You can read about
the assignments.
Basically, generally, what we're
going to do is have a
beta submission in which we're
going to test everything.
And we're also going to
take all your tests.
We're going to throw all the
tests into a big pool and run
everybody's tests against
everybody software.
You will lose points if you
fail some of the tests,
assuming the tests are
correct tests.
You will lose points if you
have an incorrect test.
You will lose points if somebody
passes your test and
they have a bug.
You will get points if your test
picks up something that
very few other groups
tested for.
So you have to both submit code
and submit tests, which
is OK, because you've got to
test your own stuff before you
hand it in.
But we're also going to be using
it to test each other.
After beta, we will have a
design and code review with
your master.
And let me just say, the
master's there not affecting
your grade in any way.
They do give us reports about
what happened in their
meeting, but they have no
bearing on the grade.
They're just there to help.
So you don't have to
view them as--
they're not part of
the course staff.
If you want to get angry at
somebody about how things are
done, get angry at
Saman and me.
Don't get angry at them.
The final submission is
generally due a couple weeks
after the beta.
And it's after you've gotten
feedback on your design,
feedback on things.
We'll give you the whole
battery of everybody's
regression tests, so you can
test out your code against
everybody's regression
test and use that.
And then generally, the scoring
is such that people
who get fast code
get high marks.
People who get slow codes
get lower marks.
If you need help,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Speed is fun.
Enjoy the class.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: In terms of
the bug testing, I'm
thinking of bugs like--
I don't know--
[INAUDIBLE]
or something like that.
If you happen to not have made
a bug in your own program
[INAUDIBLE]
would that count against you
in the final testing.
PROFESSOR: You have to view
your beta test as testing
other peoples' code also.
PROFESSOR: But if you
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] a test that
finds bugs in somebody's
program, and if very few
people wrote that test, then
you will get points.
So you don't have to test for
the world, everything.
If you fail somebody's test,
but not yours, you will be
deducted points.
If your test finds other
people's bugs, you will gain
points for that.
But on the other hand, if you
don't have a test for--
what you said, I think you don't
have to go and test for
every possible condition
in there.
The negative side is, if
you miss something,
we will deduct points.
Positive side is, if your test
finds somebody else's bugs,
you'll get points for it.
We'll go into detail exactly
how [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Another thing we did last
year, which was kind of
interesting--
I think there were mixed--
some people really liked
it, some people
were not that happy--
is a little bit of competitive
grading.
So here, what we are doing
is not the full grade--
small part of the grade.
What you do is when you first
submit your beta, rerun
performance tests
of everybody.
And of course, one of you
are going to get the
fastest code for that.
At that point, we are going
to say, OK, this
is the fastest code.
And how [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
everybody else with that code?
And the person who gets fastest
code for that part of
the grade gets the
full points.
And everybody else will get a
partial part of the points.
However, you get a chance in
your final submission to
basically improve your code.
If you do better than the last
time's best code, you won't
get any more additional points,
because then we don't
want to create
[? an arms race. ?]
So you at least had to
match the previous
times to get full points.
So you get a chance to see how
you stand against your peers
and get a chance to actually
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] math with
your peers.
So first time we did it, we
said, OK, it's the fraction of
your performance against the
performance of the best code.
The problem was, there were a
couple of codes that 1000x
performance improvement,
and everybody got 10x.
So you've got, like,
0.25 grade.
That didn't help.
So now we actually are doing
a logarithmic log scale.
So we'll get the fraction, and
we'll take the log off that.
So there will be a little
bit more equality.
So you will know how worse off
you are, and you get a chance
to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Because it is very important,
because a lot of times, there
might be a crucial thing
that you missed.
And instead of trying to be,
"aha, got you" in this class,
we are trying to give you a
chance to actually learn.
So if you missed it, OK, you
missed it the first time.
But you get the second chance
to come and fix it and see
whether you can do well.
And of course, if you do better
than the best grade,
there are bragging rights, but
you don't get extra points.
With that, let me--
where are we?
So again, as Charles pointed
out, I'm pretty excited about
this class.
This is a really fun class.
Unfortunately, I'm a little
bit under the weather.
So I'm going to sit down.
And if I don't sound that
enthusiastic, hopefully I'll
get enthusiastic later.
And that's one reason we ask you
to come forward, because
we don't have to come
here and shout.
So hopefully people in
the back can here.
If you don't, still, there are
some seats in the front.
You can move forward.
So for the rest of the class,
what we want to do is go
through an example and look at
why performance matters.
For that, I selected
matrix multiply.
And I think your Project 0,
you are going to also play
with matrix multiply.
And I think that you'll get a
feel for what kind of things
will happened and how much
room you have in
doing well in here.
And at the same time, as I go
through this, you'll get a
feel for what's the process that
you might be following
through the class and what
kind of things--
because linear programming,
after taking a bunch of
programming classes, probably,
you have a methodology set up
in your mind, how to go
about doing that.
And the same thing after this
class, we want you to have a
methodology of going through
and improving performance.
And this is basically a little
bit of a contrite example, but
you'll get a feel.
So what's matrix multiply?
It's a very fundamental
operation for many
computations.
So you are going to produce
Matrix A by multiplying Matrix
B and C. So you want to
calculate each value in here
to take a row of B and a column
of C, and you get each
element of A. And you do that
for every element of A. And
this is the possible simplest
code you can write in a
language like C, a
[? three-loop nest, ?]
and this matrix multiply.
So, so far, things should
be pretty simple.
So what I did was I looked at
matrix multiply and said,
look, you have taken software
engineering class.
You have thought about
object-oriented programming,
lot of nice techniques
to build very
useful, portable software.
And let's try to write
matrix multiply with
some of those concepts.
So the first thing I want to
do is matrix multiply write
object oriented using immutable
classes, and that,
in fact, I want matrix class
to represent both
integers and doubles.
So here's my class
structuring here.
And actually, I'm going to show
you a bunch of code now,
next couple of slides.
I'm not expecting you
to follow everything
instantaneously.
I'm going to go through
somewhat faster.
But you have the slides.
So I always expect you to,
perhaps, in some free time, to
go and look at some of the
slides, get a little bit of
better feel for what happened.
So here's what matrix
multiply does.
I have a value class that
figures out the matrix type.
And if it's integer,
it keep integers.
If it's a double,
I keep a double.
And here, basically, do
this value in here.
And then I have a
matrix class.
Basically, given a matrix type
and a matrix, it can create a
matrix here.
This basically creates your
matrix in here by first
creating a bunch of rows here,
and then instantiating each
row in here, whether it's
integer or double, depending
on the type you want.
And then, of course, there are
other things in matrix,
basically, in here.
And you can update a matrix.
This is going to be a little
bit interesting.
I will give a little bit here,
because what I'm going is I'm
doing immutable types.
That means I can't change
anything in the matrix.
If you are updating, you have
to create a new matrix.
So I'll show a little
bit about how to
go about doing that.
And then there's
this row class.
I'm going through this
fast, because
it's not that important.
If you get a chance, go through
this and get a feel
for what I'm doing.
But the idea is doing this very
software engineering way
of implementing a
matrix multiply.
So then here's my matrix
multiply in here, that what
I'm doing is I'm updating each
of these matrices by giving a
value of B and C and
adding it to A and
updating A again in here.
So when I run matrix multiply,
1,024 by 1,024 matrix, this is
the time I got.
Actually, it took a long
time, in fact.
And the key thing, is the
performance good?
That's the first question
to ask.
Because you run, you
get a result.
When the result is correct,
OK, great.
You get the correct result.
But how do you do?
And this is sometimes a very
hard thing, to know that you
have a problem is itself
a huge win--
that you figure out you
have a problem.
And what I'm going to do is go
through a little bit of a
calculation to see
how we did it.
It took about five hours to do
this matrix multiply, and that
doesn't look right already.
So if you think about matrix
multiply, it's an N-cube
operation, basically, what
matrix multiply is doing.
That's the algorithmic
[? class. ?]
If you look at Charles' book,
that's what it would say.
It's N-cube operation.
So this is the number of
operations you want to do.
And for each matrix operation,
you only do three index
updaters, add, a multiply,
and a check--
probably six ops to
do, basically.
And that means I need to do
this many operations.
Basically, you can think about
machine operations to do,
basically, because you have to
read three values, update one,
do a multiply and add,
and do a branch.
And if I look at that with my
hours, I am doing this many
operations per second,
which looks high.
Big number.
But my machine, actually, on my
somewhat old PC, transfers
even much faster.
So if you think about it, I am
taking about 8,300 cycles to
do any kind of a machine
operation.
This doesn't look right.
So at this point, this is what
I would call a "backup
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] calculation."
I haven't proven anything.
This one worked well in the
theory class, but if you can
just jot down a couple of these
things, you can get a
feel for where you
stand very fast.
And then you realize, OK, I
am a couple of orders of
magnitude off here on what
best I could do.
And that should give you a
feel for what's going on.
OK, so what's going on here?
How can we improve
performance?
Because we know we
have a problem.
So what we can do is
we can look deeply
into the program execution.
And at some points, OK, this
program runs slow.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
time spent.
So we can figure out time spent,
basically, things like
by method--
which method you spend most
of the time running.
Sometimes by line.
And we will learn a bunch of
profiling tools that will give
you this feel.
So instead of reading a million
lines of code, looking
at every line in there, you can
very fast converge onto
the culprits where most of
the time being spent.
And that's a very easy way
of triaging your problem.
And you look at things like time
spent, cumulative time
spent within that and everything
called underneath,
number of invocations
of the functions.
And a lot times, you have a feel
for what it should be.
And when you look at this, if
it doesn't look right, you
say, wait a minute, this goes
against my intuition.
Perhaps there's a problem.
So what you can do is, by
doing this, you can
identify hot spots.
Basically, if 90% of the time
it's it one routine, that's
what you want to fix.
And hopefully, that routine is
doing something too slow.
Then you can actually get good
performance in here.
So here's the profile I ran
for a matrix multiply.
And interestingly, what I found
was, most of the time
spent in basically creating
doubles--
number of calls, time spent
here, this much time was
spending, basically creating
new values in here, this
initializing a double in here.
So I'm doing matrix multiply.
Why should I be initializing
values?
So this is an issue.
And I have the most number
of calls to that too.
So we can go look at it and say,
hey, that would seem to
be a problem here.
So the problem here was
kind of obvious.
What happened was I didn't use
immutable [? class. ?]
So this is my matrix
representation.
I have a bunch of pointers
pointing to each row.
And now assume I won't
update this element.
And of course, I can't modify
the entire thing.
It's immutable.
So what I had to do is create
a copy that updates.
And then, of course, I had
to create a new matrix.
I don't have to copy everybody
else, because these guys were
not changed.
So I can place a pointer to
these things and create this
new matrix that points
to these things.
And then, if you think about
what's going on, in fact, and
this is my new matrix after I
do that, I [? updated ?] two
end copies for each update,
because what I had to do is I
had to copy this entire
row up to get that.
And I had to create this entire
index again for each
point in each row.
So just to update one element,
I am creating two end copies.
So what that means is now our N
cube matrix multiply ends up
being N to the power
of 4 algorithm.
So suddenly, you realize, wait
a minute, I'm doing something
bad in here.
I'm actually [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
N-cube algorithm, and the way
I saw, it becomes n to the
power of 4 because I'm making
all these copies in there.
So this is a bad thing
to do, of course.
And copying is very costly,
because you're making
duplicates in here.
And of course, you're creating
a huge amount of garbage,
because you are just copying and
leaving the previous value
for garbage collection.
So garbage collector's coming
up all the time, and huge
memory footprint.
So this is no good.
And can we do better?
Hopefully, we can.
So the next thing we did was,
OK, just get rid of these
immutable types.
That seemed to be a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
here.
And then, I actually have--
I will go faster over the
code, so if you are
interested, you can go look
at the code in here.
So here, what we did was, still
we have the issues like
object oriented and ability
to represent both
integers and doubles.
So what that means is each
matrix can be the integer
matrix or a double matrix.
So this is where you're
instantiating with integers or
doubles in here.
So we do that.
And how much you think this
can improve performance by
doing that?
In fact, this was pretty nice.
I actually got a 219x
performance improvement
because I went from n to the
power 4 algorithm to n to the
power 3 algorithm.
So here is interesting,
algorithm has changed with it,
and we have a pretty nice
performance improvement.
So if I look at this now, what
I find is I'm spending a lot
of method time, I'm doing
matrix multiply.
That's good.
But I'm spending all
this time doing get
double and get methods.
I'm trying to do matrix
multiply.
Why am I spending all this
time trying to do
get double and get?
What I found was issue is the
method call overhead.
Now, what happened is matrix row
has two different matrix
types, the integer row
and double row.
So every time I want to get a
row, I don't know if I have
integer row or double row.
I have to do a look-up to
figure out my type.
Am I working with the integer
matrix or matrix in doubles?
And this is what we call
"dynamic dispatch." So instead
of knowing exactly the methods
we are to go, I had to
actually look up, OK, which
method I'm supposed to go.
I have to do that since, if the
matrix is integer, I might
have to call a different method
than matrix is double.
I have to check that.
And then that call, instead
of direct call,
becomes indirect branch.
I have to check that and
basically branch on that.
And these indirect branches are
costly, because what that
means is I don't where I am
going until I do that test.
So no machine--
we'll go into details
and pipelines and
stuff as we go on.
What that means is normally,
a machine can have a lot of
instruction in flight.
So that means that I have to
know a lot more information to
get the instructions going.
But here, until you resolve the
instructions, you can't do
the next one.
So it's called a, basically,
pipeline stall.
So instead of having hundreds
of instructions going,
basically, suddenly I can't do
anything until the previous
instruction is done.
So the machine slows down
a lot because of this.
Normally, what you can do
is keep fetching next
instructions here.
We have to fetch, test, then the
test result is available,
then that's when you can fetch
the next instruction.
Let me go through that file.
So direct batch means target
address is known.
You can fetch ahead of the
targets/ If I know where I am
going, even if I don't get
there, I can fetch ahead of
the target.
I can go start fetching what
happens next ahead, basically,
into [? the branch. ?]
Sometimes, you can even fetch
both directions, or the
direction you might always
go might get
fetched by the architect.
We'll talk about a lot of
architecture details in the
future lectures.
Indirect branch means until I
calculate the address, I have
no idea where I'm going.
That address is only
calculated.
And because of that, hardware
slows down like crazy.
So this seems to be not a good
thing to have these integers
and doubles instead of having
one nice class of just
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
might be nice.
I just basically create
a double class.
It's all matrices are doubles.
If I want integers, I will just
rewrite my matrix class
or copy and replace.
Now my matrix class becomes
much more simpler.
This is what I got, and this
is my row in here.
And voila, minute I do that, I
basically went up about a 2.4x
performance improvement, because
now I don't have to
keep doing that.
And altogether now, I have
improved my performance by
about 500x here.
And for ops per cycle, we
have gone down from
8,000 to 38 to 16.
So we do still better.
And now we look at, again,
my profile data.
And what I see is, OK, I am
spending a lot of time in
matrix multiply.
That's OK.
But also, I am spending time
in this matrix get method.
I am trying to get each,
basically, row and data
elements of the matrix.
So here is the summary
of these things.
I'm going to just keep that
one, because I gave you
[INAUDIBLE].
So the problem in this
object-orientedness is I
[? handle ?] each row is
represented separately--
nice objects.
These objects overload
the memory.
And in fact, if I want to get to
my row, I have to appoint a
[? chase ?]
to go get that.
It's not contiguous in memory.
And to get to every row, I have
to actually go through
this [? point ?] indexing
in here.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] matrices are
one, nice, simple objects.
So we can say, OK,
wait a minute.
This method call overhead
actually keeps dominating.
And because I have done this
nice object-oriented thing in
here, so I can get to the
object-oriented file here and
say, OK, get to the objects.
And I write this nice loop
of [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And I have two-dimensional
matrices in here.
And voila, I got another
2.2x performance
improvement in here.
OK, now I am down to about
seven cycles for each
operation in here.
That's good.
So what can we do here?
So we did all of these things in
Java, because it's supposed
to be a nice language.
But Java has a lot
of overhead.
It's like you do memory-bound
checks.
You have to do this bytecode
interpreter
and stuff like that.
On the other hand, C can
run much faster.
You don't have to do any kind
of memory-bound checks.
The compilation happens before
you run, so it is not part of
your cost of doing anything.
So this can work very much like
C. You can just almost
cut and paste.
And if you know, C is
[? index chain, ?]
[? and this ?]
to C is just changing
a few lines.
And I did that, and this is,
basically, the C code in here.
This is the matrix multiply.
This is the kind of allocation
in here.
C can be a little bit
painful to allocate.
This is my matrix multiply.
It will look similar.
And I got 2.1x just by going
from Java to C. This, I was
surprised, because that piece of
Java code looked very much
close to C. But by just doing
that, I actually got another
2.1x performance gain.
Now this is kind of the
high-level stuff.
Now we have to go
to nitty-gritty
details in the hardware.
So in modern hardware, there
are these things called
"performance counters" that
hardware [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that we can look at what's
happening inside hardware.
We can get a feel for what
happens inside hardware.
And there are things called CPI,
which clock cycles per
instruction.
So that means if the
instructions are running very
slow, you will have multiple
clock cycles per instructions.
That means instructions
are stalling.
Something is wrong.
Cache misses.
So data [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[? pay attention to ?]
caches and stuff like that.
If data are supposed to be in
cache and have cache hits all
the time, but if you are
getting cache misses,
something is wrong.
Accesses are not good.
And then also the instructions
retired.
That means, how many
instructions are being
executed and retired?
If you are doing too much
work, the number of
instructions retired will
go high in here.
This will give you a few how
many [? work been done. ?]
So if you look at this one,
I have a CPI of 4.
That means for every
instruction, need about almost
close to five clock cycles,
which is not good.
I have pretty high cache
miss rate, too--
L1 cache miss rate and some
L2 cache miss rate.
This shows how many instruction
are in what they
call [? vector in the ?]
instruction form called SSE
instructions.
And here's the number of
instructions got retired.
So we just use that
baseline case.
So one thing I can look at was
my cache miss rates seem to be
pretty darn high.
What might be happening here?
So if you look at matrix
multiply--
so I have Matrix A in
here and Matrix B--
what happens is, to calculate
this value in [? Matrix A ?]
here, basically, I'm going to
go through this row in here,
and I'm going through
column in here.
Problem with the column is
it's all [? low in ?]
the cache.
This is your linear memory.
So because this is here two
dimensional, but inside your
hardware, there's no
two-dimensional memory.
You have a linear memory, so
this is your linear memory.
This is how the memory
look like.
And this is how the
memory look like.
So each row and column
is in these areas.
But here, to calculate this
value, this is nice.
I go through memory that
is contiguous.
But C, I am jumping all
over my memory.
And jumping on memory is not
that great cache behavior.
And contiguous can do much
better, because what you do
is, when you get a cache, you
get a cache line that has more
than one word.
So in here, what you're doing is
you are getting large cache
lines only using one word before
you go to the next one.
So that's not great
in cache behavior.
So what you can do is you can
make this memory contiguous.
So what you can do is, in matrix
multiply, normally, n
to the cubed computation
to the squared data.
So to help on n to the cubed,
it's OK to do some n to the
squared processing.
That means you can do a data
transport before you start
matrix multiply.
Do some pre-processing.
So this will also
come in handy.
A lot of these problems you'll
do, you'll say, wait a minute,
can I do a pre-process that's
cheaper that will really
improve my main processing?
This is a theme that comes
again and again.
And then we can get this n to
the cubed running faster since
this n to the cubed is much
larger than n to the squared.
You can amortize the
cost of doing that.
And basically, to get that, we
can transpose some matrix
going into the squared
operations.
And then now n to the cubed
might run much faster.
And in fact, what I have done
here is do the transpose of
this matrix.
And now we run this one, and
then everything will be in
contiguous memory.
And voila, I got another 3.4x
performance improvement.
Now I am running almost
at one cycle per op,
which is really nice.
But modern superscalars actually
can do better, so we
can actually end up
being even better.
So let's see.
So we are doing that.
So here is the interesting
thing.
Now I look at my transpose
[? spot. ?]
So if you look at that number of
retired instructions, it's
more or less the same.
Number of SSE instructions,
I have a 2x improvement in
my L1 cache miss rate.
But more than that, I have a
5x improvement in the CPI.
That means my instructions
are stalling a lot
less now than before.
So this is where I got all my
performance [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
because my instructions are
running much faster.
So by looking at data--
this is the kind of
things you're
learning during the class--
then you can get a feel for what
actually is happening and
why you are getting that.
You can go do more in the
cache, in memory system.
So remember, the memory
system, if you're
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], if you look
at cache, what they're doing
is we have a small amount of
memory called cache that are
very fast access.
And you have a large amount of
memory that is sitting out
that has slow access.
So what you want to give user
feel as if they have a lot of
memory, everything is
very fast access.
So hardware does a lot of crazy
things to give you the
illusion that you have very
fast memory and you have a
huge amount of that.
Of course, that's not true,
because you have these caches.
And what happens is, if
you do things wrong,
these get to slow down.
So in the cache system, you have
cache [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
You have each multicore going to
its own L1 cache that goes
L2 cache, which goes to L3
cache, which goes to the main
memory system.
And you want all of the
data to be here.
If that's the case, things
run very fast.
If not, you have to go here.
It will be a lot more
slow, here, even
slower, here, very slow.
So the key thing is to get the
data as much as possible here.
So here's the kind of
cycles, basically.
One cycle to get here--
three cycles.
If you go to L2 to L3, you
have to do 14 cycles
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
If you go to L3 to main memory,
you might sometimes
get hundreds of cycles
delaying here,
so it's very costly.
So the caches are very
temperamental beasts.
They work beautifully, but when
they don't work, these go
really haywire.
So a lot of times, if there's
a performance issue, look at
the cache miss rate
and say, aha, the
caches are not behaving.
And can I help in here?
So the interesting way
to look at that is
how much data I touch.
These graphics didn't show up.
Let me explain.
So if you do matrix multiply,
I am trying to calculate one
value in here.
So this is one value.
I have to calculate row
and the column.
This slide got screwed
up a little bit.
So just look at this calculating
[? row bar. ?]
So if I want to calculate a
row of values here, what I
have to do is I have to get this
row in B, and I have to
use entire C to calculate one
row of A. That means I have
touched this much data items
just to get one row of A. So
that means I am calculating
1,024 values of A. I am
touching this much data
items to get that.
On the other hand, if I do block
matrix multiply, that
means I calculate, basically,
a block in here.
This block is also 32 by 32.
It has 1,024 elements in here.
But I only need a block
here and block here.
Voila, I only have looked
at 25,000 elements.
I got the same number of
output calculated.
But I have only touched much
less elements altogether to
calculate that.
Do you see that?
And nice thing is, if this thing
fits in the cache, I am
much better than this might
not fit in the cache.
So I can calculate blocks in
matrix multiply by looking at
a lot less number of data,
that has a good chance at
fitting in cache-- and of
course, when you calculate.
you make sure it
fits in cache--
than trying to just calculate
row by row.
So one thing you can do is--
this is a lot of common
things we do.
There's many ways to
get same results.
You can change the
execution order.
You can change the algorithm.
You contain data structures.
And some of them actually
might do
better than the other.
And here, we can actually say we
can do the execution of the
change and make sure we are only
looking at small amount
of data, you get the same number
of data calculated.
And of course, sometimes you
have to be careful, because if
you do things in different
order, you might not get the
exact same results.
So if you are a numerical
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], you say, OK,
of course, if you're doing A
plus B plus C, what order you
do will make a difference
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So if you're really careful, you
can't do too many things.
But most times, you can do
some of these things.
And in fact, in our final
thing, we might say--
the final project--
we will give you something
that you can change the
algorithm as long as the outcome
of the [? image ?]
is the same.
If you look at the [? image, ?]
and the
[? image ?] outcome
is the same, you
can go change things.
So a lot of times, you might
have a lot of freedom to
change the amount of errors you
get, the precision, and,
in fact, doing that, that you
can actually get a lot of good
performance.
So in here, we are not trying
to change the matrix
multiply, of course.
But we are going to change the
way order of operations is
being done.
So some people say you
can't do that.
It would make matrix
multiply different.
But in most cases, it's OK.
So what we have done is
done what we call
block matrix multiply.
So instead of calculating
rows, you
calculate blocks at a time.
So calculating each block,
you only need a
few amount of data.
So this is block matrix
multiply.
And voila, by doing block matrix
multiply, I got even
1.7x performance
gain from that.
Now, it's very interesting.
Now with each block cycle, I
am doing two operations.
So my [? superscale ?]
is finally coming to being.
So every clock cycle,
I am doing
multiple operations here.
So this is very interesting,
the number here.
So now when you look at what
happens here, I am actually
executing a little bit more
instructions here.
Why?
Because I did block
matrix multiply.
That means I am doing a little
bit more overhead in here.
I have more loops in here.
My inner loops are small.
So I'm doing more instructions
to do execute there.
So I'm doing more instructions,
but I have a
huge cache performance gain.
My cache miss rate now going
down to very, very little--
0.02%.
And I have an 8x improvement in
cache, and that means I got
a 3x improvement in
my CPI in here.
That's very nice.
That means even though I'm doing
a little bit more work,
my cache behavior really, really
helped me in here.
So kind of says why I am getting
this performance gain.
So what else can we do?
We can go look at trying to do a
lot more crazy optimizations
because if you look at the
modern Intel, they have this
thing called [? retro ?]
instructions.
We'll get a little bit more
detail into that later.
And what we can do sometimes is
you can nudge the compiler
to take advantage of
these instructions.
Of course, if nothing helps, you
can actually go write to
assembly [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But hey, I don't want you guys
to write assembly code, at
least in this class, even though
you can get really good
performance sometimes.
But you can kind of give enough
hints to compiler and
pray and kind of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
there's no nice way on these
things, and hope for the
compiler to do the
right thing.
So in here, we can play
with, a lot of
times, compiler flags.
And this is not exact size.
We keep trying those things, and
sometimes we can even get
information back and say, OK,
what did the compiler do?
It might give you some good
hints and say, I couldn't do
something because of this
part of the code.
And worst comes to worst, you
can actually generate assembly
and stare at it.
And sometimes in this class,
you might actually want to
stare at assembly and see
what goes on in here.
So here is the assembly
for here.
And this is my loop
body in here.
And then what I can see, I'm not
going to go through that.
Everything is converted
into SSE instructions.
At least I know what SSE
instructions mean, so this
seems to be doing well,
so I'm happy.
And in fact, I'm really happy
because I got a 2.8x
improvement by doing this.
Now what I am actually doing
each clock cycle about
[? five of my ?]
operations.
So I'm going really
fast in here.
So now, incidentally, I'm
running my program about
30,000x faster than
when I started.
So if you haven't noticed,
these things
slowly add up in here.
And now, if we look at what's
going on here, it's very
interesting.
What I have done is actually, my
each instruction is now CPI
has gone down.
That means each instruction is
running slower because I'm
doing these SSE instructions.
And in fact, my cache miss
rate has also gone up.
But I am doing a lot less
instructions, because SSE
means in one instruction,
I am doing a vector.
So I'm actually getting four
operations done in one
instruction.
So the number of instructions
I execute has
drastically gone down.
So even though my instructions
are running a little bit
slower, I can basically amortize
that, and I get good
performance in here.
And of course, this one says,
OK, now 88% of the
instructions are SSEs.
So I have [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
most of the things to run
on vector mode in here.
And of course, you can keep
doing more and more and more.
And there are these four things
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] matrix
multiply, there are people who
spend their entire lifetime
trying to run it faster.
And they have libraries like
that, and this thing called a
BLAS library and this thing
called Intel Math Kernel.
So they have done a lot more
other things, like
pre-fetching, getting
everything right.
So here what I do is basically
call their library, don't do
anything myself, and this
library will do it for me.
And in fact, that library itself
gave me another 2.7x
performance gain in there.
Now I'm actually doing 11
instructions every clock cycle
by doing that.
And if I look at it carefully,
what they have done is they
are also very into SSE heavy, so
they are running almost the
same amount of instructions.
But they managed to actually
get, again,
a better miss rate.
They probably figured out some
stuff in here, things like
pre-fetching instructions.
And that means they actually
brought down the CPI back to
where it was before.
And that's why they gave that
performance [INAUDIBLE].
And finally, we are
doing a little
bit of parallel execution.
So as you know, multicores
are here.
And you're actually going to
these 12-core machines, which
is really nice.
Fastest possible machines
you can get your
hands on these days.
And it's kind of fun
to work with them.
And we can basically get
concurrency for parallel
performance.
And a large part of this class
at the end is trying to get
good parallel performance.
But there are a lot of issues
with parallelism.
I will go a couple
of issues now.
Of course, when we get to that
part, we will go in detail.
One thing is called
Amdahl's Law.
Because if you're trying to run
something parallel, you
can't run everything parallel.
When you start something,
there's part of the code that
basically starts the
computation.
And then there are the parts you
can run parallel, and then
other parts you have
to also wind down,
measure, things like that.
So what Amdahl's Law says is,
even if you have an infinite
number of processors, the
maximum speedup you can get is
this-- this the part of the code
that are sequential and
[? parts of ?] the code
are parallel.
That means if you have only
90% of the code can be
parallelized, the maximum
speedup you can get is 10,
even if you have an infinite
number of processors.
So 99% of the code is parallel,
the maximum speedup
you can get is 100.
So this is very interesting,
because even if you have huge
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], if your code
has a certain amount of
sequential part, there is a
limit of what you can do.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
also think of load balancing.
That means when you get
parallel, what you are
assuming is all processes
are busy all the time.
That's very hard to achieve.
Sometimes some processes
are busy.
Sometimes others are not.
Sometimes something's
finished early.
So if that happens, even though
you have parallels, you
might not get really good
performance in here.
And then, of course, there's a
thing called granularity of
parallelism.
Normally, what happens in
programming, you run
sequential part, you run
parallel part, you run
sequential parallel part.
To start parallelism
is a big task.
You have to tell all the other
processors, OK, look, you guys
have some work.
Go do that, and finish
that, and come back.
And that itself is
very expensive.
And the work you give
is very small.
You give the work.
The start-up and tear-down cost
of parallelism itself
might be too much than
the speedup you get.
In fact, you can make programs
parallel and slow them down
really drastically.
So you have to be very careful
in that, because you can say,
oh, I'm running in parallel,
but it's running slow.
Why?
Because you might have a
granularity issue, because we
are giving so little work that
even though you're getting
parallelism, you might not get
that much performance.
So if you look at matrix
multiply, what happens here is
you can divide the matrix into
two different parts in here
and calculate as two different
matrix multiplies in a
different core or a
different process.
Or in here, I can make it two
or whatever in matrix
multiplies to do that.
So this is nicely
parallelized.
No big issue in here.
And when I parallelize, I got
rather 3.5x performance
improvement.
Of course, I could have gotten
more here, but because I had
to start here, since I didn't
want to wait for a week for
this to finish, I had to come up
with a smaller matrix size.
But now, when I get here,
this is so fast, my
granularity is too small.
So that's why I didn't get--
because this was an eight-core
machine, I didn't get 8x
because the minute I get
parallelism, it just is over
because it's running
so fast in here.
Now, at this point, using eight
cores, I am actually
getting 36.
So this is not that interesting,
because this is
not running on one core, every
clock cycle, I am trying to
get 36 operations done.
So the interesting thing to
follow in here is that this
example might be somewhat
contrived, because I started
with this immutable-type
matrix multiply.
Hopefully, you and your
colleagues who haven't taken
this class probably
won't go that far.
But even if you start somewhere
here, still, there's
a huge gain to be made.
So to put this in perspective,
OK, so if you look at here,
even if I start here somewhere
out in C, I already got 131x
performance improvement.
That's huge.
So that means in this
class, we are not
talking about small things.
And in fact, this is why I had
to go log scale in doing
absolute grades, because we
had people who figured out
exactly how, in some problems,
to change data structures,
change execution ordering, do
some really cool thing, get
1,000x performance
improvement.
And there are other people who
did little bit things and got
2x improvement.
So the fact that what you can
do the best here can be
really, really high.
So that's why we actually
started giving you the second
chance to also go basically see,
if you missed a critical
point, to go back
and learn that.
So to put this in
perspective--
so in summary, what
we have done is--
matrix multiply might
be an exception.
Every time you go, you might
not get that much, but in
here, going from this very
software-engineered, nice
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to a BLAS [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
I got a 296,000 times
performance improvement.
This is huge.
If you put this in perspective,
if you look at
miles per gallon between
these two-- a
supertanker and this scooter--
it's only 14,000x, basically.
So what that means is you have
to have 20 supertankers to
basically match this
much improvement.
So if somebody can tell you,
look, I can't get a
supertanker to run at the same
miles per gallon as your
scooter, that would
be revolutionary.
But you can do something similar
in your computer.
And in fact, if you look at
these large data centers, the
computers are actually
burning a lot of
energy, a lot of cost.
And in fact, if you can reduce
that, that can have impact.
So what you get out of this
class is to think through
these programs this way.
Learn about correctness before
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
6.170, you hopefully are good
at writing correct programs.
But that's not good enough
in a lot of times.
And how to think about programs,
how to make it run
faster, there are multiple
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] necessary.
So for example, in here, it's
basically direct energy.
So can you get the data center
to burn 10% less energy,
that's huge.
For example, if you look at
today's supercomputing
centers, they spend about $10
million a year on energy, just
for the power grid.
So if you can say, I'm
[? playing with ?]
10%, that's huge.
Other thing, one thing Charles
says a lot of times is, what
performance gives you is
currency, because performance
itself might not be that
directly useful, but it gives
you currency to buy
something else.
What it is?
So assume you have a
nice application.
Your GUI is doing OK.
It's up to the point that people
don't feel stalled.
But if you want to do something
addition, if you add
a feature, you don't want to
slow down the program too
much, because your users
are going to complain.
So what performance gives you
is, if you improve the
performance, it gives you
currency, the ability to buy
some additional features
into your system.
Or you have a system that you
created a start up, and you
created this nice server
somewhere.
Suddenly, it became very
popular, and a million people
want to use your software.
And the software might not
be ready to do that.
It might just crash and burn, or
you might have to pay a lot
of money for Amazon for
the [? cycles, ?]
so by actually making programs
faster, you can make it
scalable, you can make
it efficient.
So this gives you the ability,
this currency, to go do a lot
more other interesting things
to your software because now
you can run it faster.
It gives you this margin
to play with.
So in this class, we are
going to learn a
lot about these things.
We are going to learn about
architecture, how looking at
the architectural issues,
how to identify when
something is wrong.
We are going to look at
algorithmic issues in here,
how to look at things.
We are looking at architectural
things like
memory systems, parallelism.
And also we will talk about
all the tools, so you will
actually know something
has gone wrong.
Because today, you run the
program, it runs, it runs
correctly, is it good
enough or not?
How do you identify that?
That's, I think, the very
interesting place to start.
So that's all I have today.
Make sure you get a Project 0.
And especially people who
haven't done C, we will--
Charles, are we going to
do a C remediation?
We did last time, didn't we?
OK, guys, one more thing.
Last year, we did an evening
C remediation class.
So if you know Java, if you want
to know C, we will send
out a time with TAs that will
give you kind of a one-hour
crash course into C in there.
And we will send information.
So this class moves very fast.
Get on with Project 0, and
see you next week.